c'est l'esprit j'allais dire du de
l'article 1 du Code du travail qui a été
introduit par le président de l'archet
donc j'allais dire c'est presque
l'esprit du président de l'archet qui
est prévalu dans l'eau dans nos travaux
puisque je rappelle quand même que
depuis 60 ans depuis 60 ans le régime
d'assurance chômage est géré par les
partenaires sociaux la loi de 2018 a été
introduit par le gouvernement d'Édouard
Philippe n'a fait que rogner sur les
droits des partenaires sociaux comme au
passage à la renier sur les droits des
collectivités locales et nous ce qui a
prévalu dans nos travaux c'est de
redonner le pouvoir aux partenaires
sociaux pour qu'il règle les les pour
qu'ils gèrent les règles de l'assurance
chômage parce que nous considérons que
c'est au plus près du terrain qu'on doit
effectivement pouvoir mettre en place
ses règles c'est vraiment ce qui a
prévalu dans nos travaux et ensuite nous
avons effectivement été très pragmatique
nous avons un petit dispositif qui
s'appelle le bonus malus qui vise à
pénaliser les entreprises qui ont trop
de contrats courts nous avons ramené
ce dispositif à sa juste réalité de
façon à ce que on n'est pas des charges
trop importantes qui pèsent sur les
entreprises même si les contrats sont un
enjeu nous considérons un moment donné
que l'augmentation des charges pour les
entreprises c'est mauvais pour
l'économie c'est mauvais pour le social
c'est mauvais pour le pays voilà ce qu'a
prévu dans le cadre de notre travaux
d'abord nous avons complété un
amendement qui a été porté par nos
collègues à l'Assemblée nationale qui
concernent la bande-poste aujourd'hui
quelqu'un qui abandonne son poste a
droit à la location d'auto à l'emploi
quelqu'un qui démissionne n'a pas le
droit à la location de retour à l'emploi
qu'est-ce qui se passe les gens
abandonnent leur poste ce qui est assez
peu élégant parce qu'on abandonne quand
même une équipe on ne remplit pas un
contrat pour lequel on s'est engagé et
on a droit à la location d'entourage à
l'emploi nous avons supprimé ce
dispositif considérant que l'abandon de
poste devait être considéré comme une
démission et n'ouvrez pas droit à la
location de retour à l'emploi premier
dispositif deuxième dispositif qui
concerne effectivement des personnes qui
font des CDD les contrats à durer
déterminée et à qui on propose un
contrat à durée indéterminé aujourd'hui
ces personnes peuvent refuser le contrat
à durée indéterminée et percevoir la
location de retour à l'emploi en je
rappelle que cette allocation de retour
à l'emploi dit à location chômage et
donner à des personnes qui sont privées
de façon involontaire d'emploi est-ce
qu'à partir du moment où on accepte pas
un CDI on est privé de façon
involontaire d'emploi la réponse est non
donc nous avons considéré que quelqu'un
qui refusait un certain nombre de CDI
après un CDD n'avait pas droit à la
location de retour à l'emploi et enfin
on a amélioré de façon considérable un
dispositif sur la validation des acquis
de l'expérience parce que nous
considérons que c'est un dispositif sur
lequel il faut s'appuyer pour former un
certain nombre de personnes pour demain
qu'on puisse créer plus de richesses
dans notre pays et plus d'emploi